skiers
good morning everybody
um this is environment agriculture we
are going to get underway with our work
session this morning but before we do I
would like representative coulon please
foreign
look at my schedule
got it yeah so it's going to go in the
same order okay so
um
first order for SB 161 which is relative
to exemptions from rabies vaccinations
for dogs cats and ferrets so I'd like to
open up
I'm sorry
SB 162.
oh James
I would like to open up the floor for
any discussion on that bill
this is the bill where uh currently
to our so there's a there's the ability
for someone whose animal is uh medically
unable to have a rabies vaccine to get
an exemption to the vaccine and I need
to agree to a number of conditions and
currently the exemption requires the
signature of uh the the animals bat uh
second vet and the um
and the state vet and uh each renewal of
that exempt exemption requires all of
those signatures which is a a bit of a
heavy paperweight paperwork lift uh so
what this bill does is it says the first
time around you need all the signatures
and then in subsequent years if you need
to renew the exemption then you just
need your own vets signature and I think
this is makes a lot of sense so I think
we should pass it
thank you for that any other comments
representative Creighton
uh yes ma'am sure I agree with the
comment what struck me was uh
commissioner Jasper's uh testimony
um
that that they made from a department
level felt that it made sense also
okay
any other questions comments
for me I also see that this streamlines
the renewal of exemptions
and I think it's a a good bill
um
and with that I guess we can move on to
discussing the next bill on our agenda
here
does any I open up the floor for any
questions or comments regarding SB 211
that's relative to background
investigations of solid waste and
Hazardous Waste Facility permit
applicants
yet representative Murray uh thank you
madam chair I think this this uh was a
bill that came at the request of the
department to make sure that we were
keeping in line with other Federal
requirements to be able to do the
background checks if my memory served me
yes
yes apparently there was some changes to
how the FBI
handles these background checks and they
wanted just to make sure if I'm correct
that the statutes that we have are in
line with that process from the federal
government
does anybody have a problem or question
with that
great okay
we'll move on next to SB 23
establishing a study committee on meat
processing
uh I open up the floor for any questions
or comments regarding that piece of
legislation representative Bixby
so uh this bill
um
is looking particularly at the
processing of what are called
non-imetable species which would be
anything other than uh poultry uh beef
uh goat and sheep so what mostly Falls
onto this in our state is uh deer elk
and bison and it's more difficult for
these for people to get these animals
processed for a number of reasons and
this study committee would look at ways
of addressing that and also ways of
addressing our general uh the general
difficulty of getting Slaughter of
getting animals slaughtered and
processed in the state and I think it
makes sense to study it so
um and and there had been some question
about whether we should have three
senators and one rep on the on the bill
because it um uh because it's a Senate
bill and uh
have rethinking that I think
um will the study will probably get
better done done better if the Reps do
it
I'll come twice thank you first off I
concur with our representative of Bixby
and that state last statement
um
however I also think this is an
extremely important bill not only for
non amenable species but
um in lieu of everything that is going
on uh in the country and in the state
with the processing it might give us
some more insight into what we can do to
better serve the other uh animals that
we have to deal with for slaughtering
thank you representative comtwa any
other comments representative Morse
thank you I was just curious if we
decided we were going to change the date
on line 31 from November 1st 2023 to
no well I think that there was some
discussion on that
um but but I believe we're going to
leave it at that
um and I actually did have a an
amendment drafted to switch it to be
three members of the Senate and one
member of the house but I also decided
that we should probably keep it as is
and I wonder if um
if there are any people from this
committee who would be willing to
volunteer to serve on that committee
representative Contour
be willing but I don't want it there's
not someone else I don't want to take up
an extra space
okay well I'll put down representative
Bixby and representative com12 for now
I wonder if it might be um a good idea
to invite someone from Fish and Game to
be on this committee oh yeah that's
probably good idea let me let me contact
the chair of the committee and see if
they have somebody who might be willing
to serve because the thing is with these
study committees I know that the um the
house speaker is pretty overwhelmed with
many of these committees that are coming
out of these house bills
and he's very much appreciative if we
can suggest some names to him for people
to appoint to these committees so
representative Creighton uh and yes
Madam chair just uh to representative
Morris's comment
um on the date so this thing gets signed
uh by the governor sometime June July
the committee forms August September and
the due date is November
is that enough time for them to do
I mean it basically gives me two months
to do the study by the time everything
gets
yeah sure yeah I'm just asking so my
only thing is if you push it out to June
we're in the middle of legislative
season January through June of next year
so really to have study committees going
on during that time is is awkward and
doesn't make sense I mean we do we
usually schedule them mostly September
October to get it done I mean yeah so
okay all right if you think that that's
enough time to do it then you're on a
committee
representative datsey uh yes um just for
clarification because I have some notes
here so the the members of the committee
shall be and is it going to be uh the
way it was originally drafted three
members of the house and one member of
the Senate that has not changed right oh
correct we would not be amending this
bill okay representative Howard
thank you madam chair I just have one
quick question
um does this is this solely not
amendable I'm um
uh animal so a species or small farms
with okay thank you
what was the answer it sounds none
okay thank you are we clear on that
everybody understand this bill and what
yeah representative
thank you and just uh to answer
representative Howard's other question
is hopefully with this study we can come
any other questions comments
thank you very much
um and now we can move on to SB a
discussion on SB 159
which is establishing a committee
another committee to study unlimited
service area permits for landfills and
out-of-state waste coming into New
Hampshire and again I would invite
anyone from this committee to volunteer
to serve on this committee
representative Murray
um the committee felt that this was an
important bill to take a look at to kind
of get a better understanding of what
what the true scope of unlimited service
area premature was with regard to
landfills and um
as you said yes another study committee
but I think when we're looking at Solid
Waste in New Hampshire we know that
there are many different facets around
it and this is one that I think requires
study thank you and I did speak with
representative evil who is the chair of
the solid waste working group and uh
asked her if they had any intention in
the near future or even farther future
to study
landfills uh you know the unlimited
service area permits and as well as
out of state waste and policies for
out-of-state waste coming to the
landfills she said no they um that even
though this is a priority and something
that they'd like to look at
there are some other things on their
plate right now that um are taking
precedence so they don't think that she
doesn't think that they're going to get
to that within the next year so
seeing as this is an important issue
um it does
um
you know make sense for a a study
committee to be formed to to perform
this work
so the process for the three members of
the house that are chosen is by the
speaker so if one of the people on this
committee is interested how's that
process work so I I'm I have discussed
this with the house speaker and he said
if I had a list of names
um to provide to him that you know he
would
um Murray you had your hand raised
um yes so I think
I think uh I guess this is a question of
the chair then so if folks are
interested how do we do we express that
to you or the speaker's office or let me
know I'll write your name down now
okay
yeah I want to be on it
okay so it looks like we have four
people who want to be on it which is a
little bit it's okay we can have more
names and we can have the
um yeah
um the the speaker choose whoever I just
need to give him a list of names because
um you know he he's gotta make the
um oh and for anyone who doesn't end up
being one of the three people who
selected uh every anyone is welcome to
go to the to all of the study committee
meetings and participate fully so uh
it's your non-voting member as a
non-voting member right so uh so that's
um you you and people who are
participating as as sort of audience
members in the uh in the hearing
generally get a fair amount of input so
anyone else have comments or questions
yeah
um
so I don't see anybody you know any
amendments coming forward for this but
I'm definitely
um with my discussions with
representative evil
um this this is not an issue that
they're going to be tackling anytime
soon so uh I I recommend that we
pass this representative Dotsy yeah uh
Madam chair just a question about
process if we are to attend those
meetings where is the meeting posted is
it in the calendar yes they would be
posted in the calendar
yeah any of this any of the study
committees after they're formed uh and
they have an initial date that they meet
they choose a chair and a vice chair and
and someone to Clerk and then um
they that will you know they they can
they then decide the um schedule of
meetings and that's posted in the uh in
the calendar Jamie helps out with that
yeah
it would be entirely possible for uh
some member on this committee to just uh
email the entire committee saying as a
courtesy saying we're having a meeting
this week at such and such a time and
place so
um it's so we can
people can be kept informed about when
the study committee's meetings are
happening except you don't happen to
pick up your calendar you can pick up
the you we can make sure it arrives in
the email
and we do have our committee researcher
Kristen Grant involved in the process
she is support for the committee and
representative NAB thank you madam chair
can I just ask procedurally is the
report language always the same for a
study committee and what is the process
by which we would review a report as our
committee
or take up recommendations
when the report comes out if our
committee is meeting and we have a work
session we can review the report and
discuss it sure and then if any ideas
come out of that for a proposed
legislation that's something else that
we would be involved in representative
Bixby yeah so typically a study
committee report will have a couple of
pages of findings uh phrased in a fairly
succinct way and then also have specific
recommendations for legislation although
it wouldn't have the the verbiage but
typically not the verbiage for the
legislation but ideas about what should
go forward is legislation
thank you
any other comments or questions about SB
seeing none thank you
um we'll move on now to SB 267
requiring the commissioner or Department
of Environmental Services to consider
cumulative impacts analysis in rules and
statutes representative Bixby okay so I
have an amendment on this just as a
reminder
cumulative impacts are so currently
rules tend to go and tend to govern
emissions and affluence uh by the single
type of emission to replement so uh the
rules for
um
for Benzene would be a certain amount of
benzene that could be emitted without
you you'd have to keep your Benzene
emissions below a certain amount but you
might have a different uh amount for
toluene and it doesn't really take into
account the toluene and Benzene might be
doing similar things biologically and
combined they might have a greater
impact than uh than they would
individually so that's one aspect of
cumulative impacts the other is that
rules tend to deal with uh individual
sources so if you have one Factory that
is emitting maybe only a third of what
the of allowed level is but you have
three other factories on next door to it
that are also emitting about one-third
of the allowed level the allowed the
amount in the that immediate vicinity
becomes uh over the you know what would
be allowed because you have have four
different emitters that are emitting a
smaller amount and that's also one
um another aspect of cumulative impact
and uh when this this bill came to the
Senate there was a initially a bill that
went to the Senate saying that they
needed to take into account
that Des needed to take into account
cumulative impacts Des said we don't
have the expertise to do that yet and uh
the Senate's response was well we'll
give you a position uh and that person
can uh study up on cumulative impacts
provide a report to uh uh and that
report
um
will the based on that report the
commissioner can suggest legislation and
uh and that and that report would come
to us as a uh would would come to uh the
Senate and the house uh and uh so uh
this is all a very good idea of one of
the one there are three minor points
that I made an amendment for one is that
uh
when they uh when it was drafted it was
going to send the report to St e and to
resources but not to us so I asked so I
put us on the recipient list for the
report I also said uh changed the
reporting out date from November 1st uh
to September 1st because we typically
have our bill filing period at the
beginning of September so uh we would
want the report before we would
potentially be writing bills about it uh
and the third
uh the Third change is in line five uh
the initial the as written the bill said
uh to determine what rules are to
determine where it says what now it said
to determine if rules or legislations
legislation should be proposed and uh I
change that to what rules or legislation
because we expect there's going to be
some changes recommended out of this and
we want to make sure that all that
information gets through gets completely
forwarded to the legislature so we have
a chance to review it and do uh any sort
of legislation that we need to in order
to address it
uh so uh I think these are pretty
um small changes and I hope everyone
okay representative Haskins thank you
um I support the amendment and I
particularly appreciate the fact that
it's going to come back to this
committee and I hope that's something
that we can consider in other bills we
discuss
any other questions comments
representative Dotsy
uh do you feel that the changes in the
amendment mandate that a study will be
done or is it still at the discretion of
I I feel that that
um as
uh as amended this will make this will
require that the study be done and that
uh and that it'd be that the reports be
provided to the appropriate legislative
committees
representative thank you madam chair
um I think by changing the word if to
what
uh is substantial because if meant maybe
but what determine what rules it really
specifies that they have to do it
okay
any other questions or comments about
I want to thank representative Bixby for
submitting this and this is amendment
1685 H is it not yes we all have copies
of that representative germana
thank you madam chair I just wanted to I
agree with uh representative comptwa
that I think that's a significant change
but it's one I support it it
specifically says any potential
legislation or rule making and the fact
that we do not currently have a process
to determine what happens when you know
multiple affluence or emissions meet in
a certain area I think makes it pretty
clear that something will come of this
so it isn't necessarily statute driven
it isn't necessarily legislation but I
think it's safe to say that since we're
currently not doing it that uh the the
report will result at least in some new
rule making so I think it is significant
but I think it is extremely important
thank you representative Bixby I just
want to note that
um this amendment is also I worked with
with Senator alt Schiller on the
amendment and this is what we uh came up
with our discussions with each other
mm-hmm
so I want to thank you representative
Bixby for putting this amendment
together it certainly improves the bill
and
um puts some
um
some impactful
language in it
um so I want to thank you for your work
okay any other comments or questions
regarding SB 267
representative Dotsy
I appreciate the fact that the changes
that
okay
um
moving on to SB 62 relative to landowner
liability under RSA 147b the Hazardous
any questions or comments regarding this
representative Bixby yeah so this was
another department request and
there were some drafting errors in
legislation about a decade ago
um plus or minus I'm not going to swear
to the exact timing but uh that needed
to be
um fixed and there were also a number of
places where there were gender
references that made things specifically
male as opposed to
um being uh
on being Universal about gender and
those were also uh changed in order to
make sure may get clear that we're
talking about anyone of any gender
um is doing the things are you know meet
these requirements so
um that's uh so I think this this makes
sense and it's pretty much a nuts and
bolts bill
okay well and uh for me um it's not only
a matter of gender it just really
clarifies you know who they're talking
about rather than he or she it's the
owner or former owner
um you know of whatever parcel
land that they're discussing here so I
think that just that in itself really
clarifies the statute
representative Murray
thank you madam chair um one of the
other things that I think the department
noticed
noted problematic phrase substance I
believe it was referenced somewhere else
in statute and so by amending that
language we are taking the ambiguity out
of what is being referenced here
no no it's already there
yeah no there's no Amendment that's the
the bill itself yeah
amending the language correct
any other questions or comments
seeing none I know um it's not uh on the
list of things to discuss today but just
as a point of information I wanted to
let the committee know that HB 79 which
was a bill that we passed
which is again another study committee
which will
um
uh it was amended by our committee to
review
RSA 426 and RSA 434
and to make sure that
those statutes are
um compatible
and that they are you know kind of
coordinating with each other and that
was made into a study committee so that
bill was passed by the Senate
and um and I believe signed by the
governor too so yes yes so uh so the
upshot of that is that it says in the
bill that we need to have the
organizational meeting of the uh for the
committee within 45 days of the
signature which means we need to get uh
some volunteers yeah so I I know that
you have stepped forward for that yeah I
did as well
um so oh we need one more volunteer okay
and representative Creighton said he
okay so we got that one covered
all right good
so now we uh turn our attention to the
uh I want to say the 800 pound gorilla
in the room which is SB 61. uh relative
to surface water setbacks for landfills
now I know we've got a lot of comment to
say on this particular bill
before we get started
I'd like to just say that I want to make
sure that our discussions
are
discussions that
do not
place any kind of motives or aspersions
or caste dispersions on any people or
organizations or businesses
this bill is about how we are going to
move forward when we have to
um amend the rules that we're currently
working on working under or that Des
Works under when citing landfills so
um
with that I'd like to open up the
discussion
representative Murray thank you madam
chair I'd like to ask if we could
because there's so much to discuss could
we maybe go paragraph by paragraph
Madam chair yes sir representative could
I suggest
um before we go into it
um
a paragraph by paragraph I'd just like
to to make a few points in terms of you
know just pointing out where some of the
the key areas of of
um contention are sure and then uh and
then we can go into a um a more
systematic discussion let's be my guess
so um
so the I think the probably the biggest
sticking point uh is the idea of
reversion uh which is that uh if the
um
if the rules are not finished within 24
months uh then the uh then permits can
be issued under the existing rules and
uh that is something that um
there uh some people find that really
unacceptable and some people find it
absolutely necessary and that's going to
be difficult not to crack uh and we can
discuss that more in more detail as it
as it comes up uh there's
um there's been a num a lot of
um
requests from a number of different
areas for a clear conflict of interest
statement and
uh there is not uh actually a template
for this at DES but they do have within
their rules uh standards of conduct for
engineers and geologists uh and uh
um the impression I have gotten is that
there doesn't seem to be a lot of
resistance to having in the bill a clear
a clearer statement of conflict of
interest in of What conflict of interest
language should go into the RFP
um so that might be a less difficult not
to crack uh one another issue that's
been raised is whether 150 000 is is
enough to attract a qualified consultant
and uh this uh one approach to that
would be that uh if that's not enough
then
um the department can approach the
fiscal committee for more it also may be
possible to put language into the bill
suggesting that although it wouldn't be
necessary in order to authorize it uh
and uh then uh there have also been
suggestions about technical technical
specifications and that's something we
can get to as we're going through line
by line and um
so that that's my general and and the
the
um this discussion points sheet that I
sent that I passed around is really I'm
not trying to push any particular point
of view I'm just saying this is some of
the stuff that's out there and uh so
that we can just get stuff on the table
okay and thank you for for outlining
some of the things at least that you see
um that need amending I I just want to
make clear that since there is some work
that we feel that needs to be done on
this bill this bill even though it is
set as scheduled uh to be exact this
afternoon it will not be because we
clearly it's not ready for prime time as
they say we don't have an any
um definite amendment in hand that we
can deal with so
excuse me
um so we will not be executing this bill
this afternoon and we will schedule it
for another time
NAB you had your hand up
um I was just going to add to Peter's
list to representative bixby's list
they're reporting out of the findings as
a discussion point
I thought that was also a sticking point
but I'm if I'm wrong I apologize but I
don't know
uh represent Potenza
yeah I want to second that
um the findings as well as
um
the dates I think are a sticking point
as well that we need to talk about
um you know the 24 months and if it's
not there in 24 months you know due to
if there's something that happens so
um in permitting I think is extremely
important as well that there are no
permits that are done until these new
the findings are in place and we have
new rules adopted
okay representative Murray yeah
thank you madam chair
um I'm happy to add that portion to the
sort of topics of things to discuss I
agree that I think we could probably add
the report out to include
um
our committee
um I don't see that that isn't terribly
onerous task to see the committee on our
report
um that said I I would like to see if we
can
go sort of uh to make sure we're not
missing any finer points uh and that is
I mean we'll definitely get there to
representative patenda and
representative um nam's points I think
that those are well okay thank you
representative Howard
thank you madam chair I just have one
question that I think will be answered
in the course of going paragraph by
paragraph but
um I'm wondering why we have a two-year
limit at all
um what we've been informed that I think
we have at least 24 years before we need
a new landfill
um before the need arises so why are we
setting a timeline
well that's something that we can
discuss but certainly that's a point
that the Senate felt very strongly about
and they reached their consensus for
that particular time period
so I mean it's their bill so that's what
okay so
um do we want we we want to proceed
representative
um excuse me thank you as we go through
this I think if we talk about the
sections so that we do you know each
section at a time and that we State what
section we're going through just so
everyone's on the same page I think is
extremely important right so we'll begin
with um the first paragraph which is the
statement of purpose uh lines one
any questions comments about that
representative Bixby I think that the um
I'm pretty comfortable with a statement
of purpose I I think that uh I like the
you know I like the fact that it
um recognizes the need for redundant
protection I like the fact that
um
there are that it um
emphasizes the idea of site-specific
requirements because it incites you know
are you know fairly variable and there
need to be requirements that that deal
with that so I don't see any I don't see
any problems with the statement of
purpose
representative Creighton yeah yes Madam
chair what I noticed on that and it's
just before the mention of site-specific
requirements
is it's the whole concept of the bill in
general is to re-examine how we do this
and so
identifying distances the the rate at
which water travels the soil conditions
all of those are inherent
in the description of the statement of
the purpose
and so as you get into the bill what
we've told them is to figure out what
these specifics are not to define those
specifics and something you don't tell
someone to do something then tell them
what it is that you just so what we're
doing is tell them to go do it so go do
your work and then come back and tell us
what those specifics are and and a lot
of the discussion and emails I've gotten
over the last couple of days have said
you know well you need to be specific in
the bill I completely disagree with that
I think that we need to be directive in
go go do your work and come back and
tell us scientifically what those
specifics are and I just wanted it says
it straight right right in the statement
of purpose and given that the I guess
the Des rules expire next year
um then you know it may this makes
perfect sense and perfect timing uh this
is a very timely Bill
to direct uh how how those new citing
rules can be developed
representative Nam
a question about line
um 15 and 16 if they are timely adopted
and what them
meaning of that language is and if it's
um to
if it's problematic at all in terms of
adoption of new rules and permitting of
um I don't believe they are
problematic okay I don't I don't think
so I mean the ACT also sets a time frame
for the Department's attached adoption
of new setback rules and requires that
any newly cited landfill Premier
permitted after the effective date
comply with the new rules if they are
timely adopted if they are timely
adopted as provided in this act so
representative
thank you madam chair I am looking at
one thing and it says here
um based on what representative
Creighton just said it says the ACT also
sets a time frame for the Department's
adoption of new setback rules and
requires that any newly cited landfill
permitted after the effect of day comply
the thing is is we're saying that the
setback rules now are are no good
because we're telling them that they
have to come up with new setback rules
and so isn't that telling them what to
they're already going to be doing
instead of having them look at
everything scientifically
just asking the question
[Music]
representative Potenza
I agree with that I think it should just
say new sites we're all talking about
how everything is supposed to be site
specific so if we have to put anything
in front of it it should be site
specific or not put anything in front of
it all and just say new rules and I
believe that that whole line should read
the ACT also sets a time frame for the
Department's adoption of new rules and
requires that any newly cited landfill
permitted and then Wipe Out the rest
permitted comply with the new rules as
provided in this act we don't need any
anything else in there that talks about
time the rest that's talked about time
will be outlined in the rest of the bill
representative Bixby so uh one thing
that's important to know about
um both the uh the purpose and the
statement of purpose and the findings is
that uh they don't carry the same weight
of requirement that the rest of the bill
does
so uh they don't become part of Statute
law uh and
uh they are basically uh outlaying the
general idea I am concerned that if we
do wordsmithing of every little bit then
that's going to raise red flags that
might uh make it less likely that the
other body would concur with this uh and
make it less likely that it gets signed
into law and I want to avoid anything
that uh is going to raise red flags
unless it's something that is really
critical for how the bill is going to
work
Creighton
thank you ma'am I would just
like to pile on representative Bixby at
the end of the day I think people agree
that this has got to pass at the end of
the day whatever we do here this we want
all of us want this to pass
and so I think looking at it from a
practical perspective of what we believe
will pass
and it's a matter of picking your fights
and I think that in this case this
verbiage I I agree with you completely
that it does allow the wiggle room if in
I agree completely with that but to to
representative bixby's perspective and I
agree with him completely is that if we
make a hundred thousand changes to this
and we redo the whole thing then we have
abjectly failed because the Senate will
say thank you but no
and so I think we do have to be very
careful
in that those things that we believe
need to be changed and I think we agree
on what needs to be changed that we
stick to that and that we do we do a
careful analysis and representative
Bixby and the chair chairman of
done coordination with the Senate so
they understand the specifics of what
probably will and probably won't pass
and I overstated my point but I agree
with both of you I do believe that this
is one case where we just choose not to
fight that fight right now and pick a
better place to fight
representative Haskins thank you madam
chair
um with respect I don't think any of us
wants to dissect it change it make you
know a dozen different changes but I
think there are two or three things that
matter greatly and I'm not yet aware
that we've reached agreement on them so
I think that's where the discussion
okay
representative germana
thank you madam chair I want to see
first of all with regard to the point
about the fact that this statement of
purpose instructs the department to
adopt new setback rules I I think it's
clear that both the Senate and this
Committee in the in the house having
heard from a lot of experts have
concluded that new setback rules do in
fact need to be uh
need to be developed so I think that is
it makes perfect sense in terms of the
statement of the purpose we're asking
them to set the new rules based upon the
the scientific analysis that they're
going to be doing and then also I just
want to clarify I believe that the the
Clause if they are timely adopted is
provided by this act defense essentially
refers to the reversion to Old rules in
the case that Des does not
finish the process right because the
they in that Clause refers back to New
setback rules so I just wanted to
clarify the meaning of that term
referred specifically to
an event where Des does not complete the
assigned work within the 24-month period
thank you
representative Howard
thank you madam chair um just to just to
revert back to representative
Creighton's original
um a statement about not wanting to be
too prescriptive I agree with that I
think that there are there are going to
be moments when we do have when we do
have to make some substantial changes
but along the way
being you know the technical things and
all that being too prescriptive I think
is going to negate the passing of this
bill
okay
um
I guess we can
we can then move on to the findings
section
does anybody have any questions about
that representative Bixby
um
I am also good with the findings section
I think that uh it uh does in fact uh
indicate that the 200 foot setbacks
doesn't make sense and that uh replacing
it with a site-specific setback is
important it also emphasizes the
importance of redundancy uh and uh so I
I think that
um I I don't find anything that is
anything problematic in the in the
finding section and I I'd be I think we
um so do you want to skip to
section three the new paragraph rule
making
uh yeah and that's lines that's page two
line 17
any questions or comments about the
rulemaking paragraph
amending RSA 149 M Collins colon seven
by inserting paragraph three the
following new paragraph
criteria for determining site-specific
setback of landfill footprint from
perennial surface water bodies
to prevent attenuate or otherwise
remediate the potential release of
contaminants to each such surface water
body from the landfill footprint and so
forth any other any questions or
comments about that section represent
Bixby
yeah so um at one point I was thinking
about
um
it says uh the department no line 23 uh
the department deems uh any other Factor
the department Department deems
necessary uh to provide adequate
protection of surface water perennial
surface water uh I at one point was
thinking that you know that's a kind of
roundabout way of just saying protect
and uh thought that maybe we should
change that but going on the going on
the principle that I mentioned earlier
that we don't want to make any changes
that aren't really necessary uh and
would create red flags I think that we
should just leave that as is uh I it
basically means the same thing even if
it spends another four words to say it
okay
representative Haskins
this is the section that gets into the
science
and
um this is where I'd like to hear from
one of the scientists who does this work
and knows it better than I do would that
um
don't know don't
I mean this is a work session for the
committee I just again this this section
I think is important for us to
understand the science and if we can
have that explained more explicitly it
would be helpful to me
yeah representative Contour
thank you madam chair I think um
because right now we're under rulemaking
and I don't know if um
if I guess unless we had the department
of
uh well perhaps
because when we get into like
site-specific perennial service order in
those sections I think that's where you
get into the really the science stuff
any other questions or comments
regarding this section
okay
um
then we're looking at section four
which is page two lines 33 to 37.
and that section discusses
um
site-specific set new paragraph for
site-specific setback to Perennial
surface water
which amends RSA 149 Dash M colon 9. by
inserting after paragraph 14 the
following new paragraph This regards to
its own in regards to formulating a
site-specific setback
to Perennial surface water under rules
adopted
representative Dotsy
yeah
can somebody explain to me what
um lines 23 24 and 25 what that sentence
means
thank you
yeah the department shall include as a
condition to any permit the
implementation of a measure proposed in
the application for the permit upon
which the department relied in
formulating the site-specific setback
required
I'm reading it hold on representative
Howard
it sounds to me as if they are they're
they're as part of the agreement to put
in the landfill they are conditions that
that are in the contract that are
separate from what that are that sound
as if they might be separate from the
rules
representative germana uh thank you
madam chair as I read this in reference
to the points one through eight above so
in the department
concludes right what the contract in
permitting is in this case if any of
these
uh measures are put in place that
measure is included in the contract that
is drawn up for the permit right so if
the the recipient of the permit agrees
to uh you know Point number five for
example and increasing the thickness of
the liner as a part of their
site-specific
work with Des that would be then
included in the contract that is drawn
up with Des that's how I read that uh
that section uh representative Creighton
I'll just frame it another way in my
mind some worries better I probably want
the words this way but if you make a
ruling you got to tell the people why
you made a ruling but that's the way I
read that and
representative Etsy
yeah then I would suggest that maybe we
make that clarification I mean I know
about word smithing but I've just read
that over and over again and I couldn't
figure it out so maybe we do need to
um
I agree that that is not uh the clearest
of language and
um
I I think that what I'd like to do with
that is
um
see if we can make sure that uh see if
we can get clarifying language and I'd
like to work with one of the Senators on
that to make sure that uh whatever
clarifying languages be language we come
up with really is
truly matching their intent uh because I
I don't want this to come off as being
us just sort of doing grammatical
correction on the senate for the sake of
you know
being the school mom I want I want to
make sure that we actually are um
getting it clarified in a way that they
would agree with and I'd I'd uh so
um I will talk with members of the
senate committee about this and see if
we can come up with a somewhat clearer
and clearer language so that it's not it
doesn't become something that's looked
at as ambiguous in some lawsuit at some
point I concur with that representative
Haskins yeah I think we've heard
testimony that there are a number of um
scientific flaws in the sections three
four and five and that's why I was
hoping we could get
some help with that since we have people
and that would add to the discussion
that
representative Bixby has with the Senate
okay
representative Creighton the one thing
that I think
um
helps us out with that is
on line two where it says without
limitations
so this is a suggested
topics
to consider you don't have to consider
all of them but if something's missed in
you sorry if something's missed in here
then by all means add it so this is is
representative Potenza
I agree with that and I understand where
you're coming from because this list
could be exhaustive it could go for
pages and pages
I think I would have rathered there to
be just some generalities in here
instead of getting they got really
specific right they probably shouldn't
have it should have been more General
because that's the whole point of us
Contracting out so
um I think at the top the without
limitation is protective for that
um even if some of these things here
might not be accurate
well I I think you're absolutely right
and it would be a huge huge list I'm I'm
happy to see some um
some really good examples though
um showcased here so this is this is a a
good list to start from
representative germana thank you madam
chair yeah I just want to Concur and say
that I see this as being comparable to
or parallel to a section in in HB 56
which the bill which a lot of us really
liked for example the project
Improvement allowances
right one or more specific allowances
I'm referring to 56 now may be added to
the calculated time based on specific
additional control technology monitoring
programs
Etc and so I see this list which is as
representative Creighton and
representative Potenza pointed out is
not it is without limitation so this is
a I I see it as being comparable to or
parallel to that section of of HB 56.
okay
any other questions or comments on this
section
okay we can move along to section five
um
which is Page Three uh line 26 going to
page four up to line 18 having to do
with the Department of Environmental
Services Solid Waste landfill setback
requirements assessment and
recommendations
uh do we have any comments or questions
on this particular section
this is having to do with
um Department of Environmental Services
Contracting with one or more qualified
consulting firms or individuals
to perform an assessment of the current
perennial surface water protection and
setback requirements that are applicable
to the permitting of newly cited Solid
Waste landfills in order to meet the
requirements of sections three and four
representative Bixby yes so um this is a
section where we might want to add more
specific language about conflicts of
interests because this is the the
conflict of interest language should be
something that is included within the uh
the RFP
or the requests for proposals so
um
so iPad I passed around a sheet that has
um it says Bixby five nine at the top
and this is this is basically the last
two pages of the bill with a couple of
amendments that I'm suggesting uh and
it's the one that says surf that has the
word service water at the very top uh if
you go down to
um uh Roman uh one uh
um then um
I I would there's some language I I'm
suggesting putting in uh so
um the draft request shall require each
proposal to provide a statement of any
potential conflicts of interest with any
entity that may benefit from any change
in setback requirements indicating that
preference the preference will be given
to bidders without such conflict of
interest or to bidders with the fewest
conflicts of interest
the draft
qualify the draft request will also
indicate that preference will be given
to proposals which demonstrate that the
qualified consulting firms or
individuals have credentials and
experience in evaluating the health and
safety risks associated with
Environmental Protection as well as the
engineering and hydro hydrological
aspects of landfill design and sighting
so that's I think that
um will
give the
still give the department a lot of
latitude in terms of the selection they
make but will provide some sort of uh
indication of what the legislature
thinks is you know appropriate for the
selection process
representative Haskins
thank you madam chair I wonder if the
phrase bitters with the fewest conflicts
of interest doesn't undercut the
statement
um
I think that representative Bixby yeah I
I think that uh depending on how one
measures conflicts of interest it may in
fact be impossible to get someone who
has absolutely no interest whatsoever uh
to uh because there are
there are you know a finite number of
firms uh in the Northeast that would be
uh probably likely to bid on this and uh
it is likely that some of them have done
work at some point or other in their uh
um history as a business with some uh
some of the entities involved here and
we we so we may not be able to find
someone who has the you know absolutely
no shred of potential conflict of
interest uh so uh that's why I put in
the the phrase
um a fewest as opposed to absolutely not
representative Creighton uh thanks ma'am
um yeah it's it's a pretty small
community a pool of folks the question
for uh representative Bixby did did you
run this by the
Senate I agree with the verbiage
um we had talked last week about
potentially extracting an existing
document right so I
um I so uh there there so
um
it turns out there is not a dra there is
not a template within the in the
department of uh
environmental services for the conflict
of interest I do have
um uh standard code of ethics for
engineers and geologists that does
reference
um conflicts of interest I have not run
this by the Senate yet I haven't run it
by uh others other stakeholders and that
is something that
um would need to happen before we you
finalize this I just wanted I wanted the
committee to have a you know to to have
a look at it and uh yeah and before I
you brought it to other people to see if
there's any if any other changes that
the committee felt needed to happen
before we brought it um
I actually think this language
um
says what it needs to say about conflict
of interest and and also
um
brings into
view the fact that yeah we are we do
have a limited number of people who
would bid on something like this and you
don't want to eliminate all of them
so it this this makes sense to me it's
I think it's well worded in the sense of
um in about a conflict of interest but
we're not defining what a conflict of
interest is so that's leaving that up to
the interpretation of the department
that's going to pick it so I know that
the
what I wrote
is
quite strict probably and needs some
work
but if you can't Define it in saying
what the conflict of interest is so for
example you have someone that's bidding
on it that wants a permit
um that have been that has been trying
to permit a landfill in New Hampshire
and they're bidding on this that's
obviously a conflict they want to get
the next contract real contract where
the big money is so I think that we have
to specifically put some stuff in there
that's that defines what the conflict of
interest could potentially be and have
them spell that out so we know that
history
I mean how to me there's no other way
representative Murray
um thank you thank you madam chair I so
I had done a little bit of of
researching and while I understand that
there might not be any
anything to
um
this within Des I did find something
referenced in administrative rules
around
um third party
um accreditation and that's with regard
to Laboratories and there was a conflict
of interest statement there
um
so I was curious to know it reads um
something to the effect of that it
acknowledged that all current or former
relationships associations or
Investments that may influence or appear
to influence judgment discretion or
impartiality
uh for Laboratories applying to or
accredited to the program have been
disclosed and then it continues on so
there are there there is something out
there
um
whether or not that's
suitable to be changed or included it
looks like this is in
and that's applications for initial or
renewal approval of tpaos
um so third parties okay uh
representative Bixby yes also for the
for the sake of um
uh well so uh in the Des
um uh conduct uh code of conduct for
engineers uh
the the language reads as follows the
professional engineer shall avoid
conflicts of interest as follows one
promptly informed his employer or client
of any business
association's interests or circumstances
which could influence his or her
judgment or the quality of his or her
services
to not accept compensation Financial or
otherwise from more than one party for
services pertaining to the same project
unless the circumstances are fully
disclosed to and agreed to by all
interested parties three
not solicit or accept Financial or other
valuable considerations from Material or
or equipment suppliers or specific or
specifying their products
for not solicit or accept gratuities
directly earned directly from
contractors their agents or other
parties dealing with his or her client
or employer in connection with the work
for which
and he or she is responsible
um
five when the pub when in public service
as a member advisor or employee of a
governmental body or Department not
participate in considerations or actions
with respect to Services provided by his
or her
organization uh in private engineering
practices and six not solicit or accept
engineering and Engineering contracts
from a governmental body on which the
principal or officer from his or her
organization serves as a member so
that's what's currently
um
in the
uh in the administrative rules regarding
Professional Standards it's the
basically the equivalent language for
geologists as engineers
representative thank you madam chair
while we're talking about conflict of
interest I'm just curious
um if when we do that and I know we're
just talking basically about the
Department of Environmental Services but
does this take into account the
executive branch that actually approve
uh representative Bixby uh that I'm not
quite so you mean does does that code of
conduct also apply to everyone in Des or
everywhere in the executive branch
correct uh that is something that I
don't technically know uh I we might be
able to get uh someone from the
Department to uh explain what they have
for their internal uh code of um of uh
representative.c
thank you madam chair it's it seems to
me like this is out of the scope of our
wheelhouse and maybe she'd be tossed
over to research or OLS I find it hard
to believe that there are no States in
this nation that have not had this same
problem and if we did research on that
we might be able to come up with the
appropriate wording that have been used
representative Haskins thank you madam
chair I like that suggestion by
representative dutsy I also picked up on
the word disclosure
and I think that should be inserted
somewhere
well we do have our committee researcher
in the room
so
um
I guess that's a question that we could
throw your way
and take a look at for us
okay representative Bixby so not only
might other states have this but we
might have it in some other context
within our state
so there there's probably some some uh
language out within our current laws
somewhere that deals with
um uh with uh addressing conflicts of
interest uh on contract on rfps and
um you know wherever that may be
as well as a definition of What conflict
I agree I think disclosure is really
important so if we are if we have a
statement of a conflict of interest and
we're act and we're asking these people
that are interested in putting in a
proposal or having this contract as long
as they're stating whatever is maybe
it's a known or perceived conflict of
interest that also it just lays it down
on the table as well so the less of
those the better of course so I know
we've talked about that there's not
um necessarily a lot of entities to do
this kind of work and we might have slim
pickings so we I knew I know we need to
be sensitive of that but in specifically
listing
what those could possibly be like I had
written out and telling those people
that they need to disclose that if they
are going to bid then I don't I don't I
don't think we need a lot of research
for that and if we want to use some of
the specific statute language that's
already in place that has been used
okay
um any other questions or comments
I'm sorry representative Knapp I just
had a question about the bidding process
what happens if only one I'm sorry I
meant section five sorry yeah okay I'm
sorry if only one contractor submits a
response to the request per proposal
excuse me say that again I just had a
question about the process around the
request for proposal if only one
contractor submits a bid or if there's
zero contractors that submits the bid is
that anything that's within our scope or
is that really a response from Des no
not not that that would be um
yeah the executive would take care of
that thank you
represent Potenza
before we're done with five
don't I think that this besides having
the conflict of interest in there
couldn't we in this area where we're
telling them
um you know under a b c and d shouldn't
we put the experience in there as well
what experience that we feel
um
the provider that's chosen should have
representative
thank you madam chair
um
I would defer to Des for experience
because none of us here
um
are experts in that area
and I think they know what they're
looking for in a contractor more so than
we could ever
and we wouldn't want to spell that out
in statute
I don't think
representative germana thank you I I
think if if in the language that
representative Bixby is provided
you know we are giving them the the word
qualified and I think that I'm looking
for the specific language here but has
to do
um
demonstrate qualified consultant
confirms uh experience in evaluating
health and safety risks associated with
Environmental Protection as well as the
engineering and hydrogeological aspects
that's precisely why we want them to do
this is because we are concerned with
the health and safety risks associated
with Environmental Protection so I don't
think it's inappropriate at all for us
to
specify what we mean by qualified in in
you know I like the language that
representative Bixby has offered to do
that
thank you
represent Potenza
that's exactly I have some bullet points
that that go from that too I think you
actually have to define the term what
qualified means so
um at least you know direct and relevant
professional experience in geologic and
hydrogeologic conditions similar to
those that are found in New Hampshire
direct and relevant experience in
environmental and health risk management
at least those two bullets
any other questions or comments
so uh representative pretended just to
be clear
um in your page that you spelled out in
experience under that paragraph you are
just talking about those first two
bullet points yes
okay
I that's why I wrote should be outlined
in the bill reflecting something similar
as listed below yeah
I know we can't put anything I do like
direct and relevant professional
experience in groundwater flow and
contaminant transport modeling in soil
saturated unsaturated conditions and in
Bedrock including highly fractured Rock
that's just because I've been
researching so
um what these people do and I'm in no
way am an expert on all of this but um
the research on it is is pretty clear
what these what a company needs to have
and I think it's really important that
not one company is going to have all of
this so we can talk about dates and
costs we're going to get into that but
it's not just one contractor
most contractors just in the nature of
this and I have experience in this are
not going to have all of the tools in
the toolbox they're going to subcontract
pieces of this out with relationships
that they currently have which will
still apply with the conflict of
interest and all of that so it's really
important that it's not
whoever is hired for this or whoever's
putting a proposal in is not going to
necessarily have all of those people
right on staff a lot of these people are
Okay I uh my my concern would be
um that those that list of if if we make
this so
um
definitive like this
will we be limiting that the pool of
applicants based on as well as the
number of contractors they may
subcontract out to because
let's face it there's there's probably
um many of these contractors and
subcontractors
who may end up having some kind of
conflict of interest at some point and
um
I just hesitate to be so
specific
that it
would
negate many of the people who might
be very good at what they do
and prevent them from participating in
in doing these and doing the study
representative Bixby yeah I I concur
with what representative Aaron is saying
I think that uh if we make it too
specific uh there are there are two
risks one is that it's going to make the
the burden of uh making sure that every
bit of language is is followed by Des is
um is absolutely you know on spot on
it's going to make that it's going to
make the process much more difficult uh
but we one of the things that we we have
to recognize is that Des has been
working in this area for decades and uh
we might not agree with everything the
department has ever done uh but we do
have to recognize that they do have a
certain level of expertise and we need
to trust that level of expertise uh
because they are the ones who are going
to be performing this work and if we
provide General guidelines like like
I've laid out in my uh in in the post
language here uh which by the way I'm
not you I don't have any ego in this I I
if if people want to change it that's
fine but I want to make sure that we
make retain it as being sufficiently
General that Des can use their expertise
to make sure that they're fitting the
language
representative Dotsy
regarding the process if we have
research research this whole issue and
maybe come back with a couple of
statements uh at that point we will be
doing another work session or we will be
able to look at at the amendment and
decide whether or not we meet our
criteria is that correct
I'm sorry say that again well I mean
I thought we had made the decision to
throw this over to research and now what
I'm hearing is that we're trying to come
up with a definition of conflict of
interest so if we do throw this over to
research to research what's been done in
New Hampshire and Across the Nation
when that information comes back won't
we have time then to determine if that
meets our criteria for conflict of
interest so why are we wordsmithing it
now so no I think what we were just kind
of exploring uh you know what what is
meant in terms of a qualified firm
and those were the bullet points that
representative Potenza had brought up
representative Haskins thank you madam
chair I agree with representative Betsy
and I also weighing in again that the
disclosure statement could handle some
concern that we have about if there are
so on is it representative Bixby can we
move on to the next section uh we'll
representative germana had his hand up
so let me just okay entertain what he
has to say
entertain me it's the right word I
suppose thank you madam chair uh you're
always entertaining yeah
I just wanted to concur with with Madam
chair as well as I think and I also want
to say I very much appreciate uh
representative Potenza in the work that
you did in in this and thinking through
it so thank you very much I just wanted
to as you say concur with with the chair
and say that I don't think we want to be
too prescriptive I think that we want to
be aware of what belongs in statute uh
and and I think that that the language
that representative Bixby uh has
proposed or something akin to it
provides
um enough room for Des to work within
without getting prescriptive in ways
that we don't want to see put into
statute so I hope that was entertaining
well worth hearing thank you
representative Howard thank you madam
chair I haven't been through many many
RFP processes
um I I would trust the DS people who are
managing this process to go through the
criteria of who they're
of of the people that they're looking at
and also their their form their
knowledge at forehand of many of these
people so that they I think they'll
they'll go into the process with a
pretty good knowledge of their abilities
and their conflicts
thank you
okay
moving on
we so we will look forward to hearing
from our committee researcher
I'm sure she's looking up something now
too
well look at uh section six uh which
goes from page four line 19.
to page five line seven
so this
um
this has to do with targeted completion
for rule making
and uh
I'm sure we'll have plenty of discussion
representative penenza go right ahead
so most of this section has to be
changed if we because a lot of that a
lot of this section then
um
coincides with the next page you know at
item three so
um
and I and I think that there has to be
wording in here of the 24 months I don't
know how that the word smithing of that
would look like that um giving their
leeway that if if the study's not
completed in time or the rulemaking's
not done in time that
um you know any of course permits are
are are held
um until those rules
um are in place uh so there's definitely
some some real work that has to be um
done here and I also
um 150 days I've had numerous
conversations with
um entities throughout the state that
are educated in this
um there is no way a a full Statewide
study that's going to be done that's
going to impact us from years to come
that we're going to be going off of
couldn't be completed in 150 days it's
just not possible and I think it should
be changed to 250 or 300 days I also
think the cost should be increased so I
can let other people
even at 250 days which is eight months
is still
um is still quite early for what we're
looking at if they're going to be all
over the state because basically you're
looking at every place in New Hampshire
that you could cite a landfill that's
what they're going to have to be looking
at all site specific so I mean from one
location to the next that is so much
work that's done on the geologic and the
hydrogeologic conditions and
um and for this to not be rushed we
don't there doesn't need to be a rush as
the representatives said earlier here
next to me
um so I you know I'd like to have a
discussion about that
okay uh I I'm not sure that
your
interpretation of the kind of study that
this bill is proposing
is in sync with well what your idea of a
study and what this bill's idea of a
study I think are two different things
um I I don't think this bill is
suggesting that
any potential landfill site in the state
has got to be studied
and I don't think that that's going to
happen
representative Creighton
yes ma'am and the way I read this bill
is that what we're directing them to do
is to define the standards
that would be used by a contractor that
would go and evaluate the site
so this bill does not in my mind
evaluate a single site
this bill
describes how those sites would be
evaluated
oh can I follow up please okay I agree
what you're saying but to do that you
actually have to study a site you have
to study the site to be able to build
you can't just go off of that's why I
know what you're saying but to develop
the rules you actually have to know the
correct
and it's so diff all over New Hampshire
is from location to location is
completely different representative
thank you madam chair
it is my understanding
and I would ask someone to correct me if
I am incorrect
the Des is going to start looking at all
the criteria right now for landfills and
what this outside subcontractor is going
to do is come up with what they think it
should be Des is going to come up with a
set of rules and they're going to take
into account what the subcontractor says
to put into rules they are not going to
be telling us the subcontra cannot
dictate
to Des what has to be done they can only
propose there'll be public hearings but
at the end of the day the rulemaking is
going to be
with des and
the fact that we're going to have an
outside subcontractor who's going to
have other subcontractors as you stated
looking at this and Des has now two
years to start the process
right to to do this I don't think
I think we're overlooking this this is
not looking at every landfill Des has
all that data about the landfills in in
their purview
they know what's going on at these
facilities due to inspections and other
things so
um
I don't think that we need to broaden
the scope so much and I think we need to
leave it as is representative Bixby
so I think it might make sense just to
refer back to on the previous page where
um where it says what is going to be
um proposed uh which is uh in section
one of that uh is it it's in it's in
section five
um starting at uh where's the wine here
on
section five let me just it's the next
page
um
uh Phi is uh section five
um section five one a
um so
um yeah so that's page four starting at
the top
and asset so
um the scope of proposal shall include
the following an assessment of the
environmental safety and Technical
aspects of Parental perennial surface on
water setback requirements and related
Protections in the current in current
state law and administrative rules that
are applicable to to the permitting of
newly cited Solid Waste landfills
recommendations for using criteria
enumerated in section three of this act
to establish site-specific setbacks
recommendations for any other factors
the consultant determines necessary to
provide adequate protection of perennial
surface water in section three of this
act
for each such recommendation the
consultant shall identify each state
that has adopted the recommended factor
and describe how such state has applied
the recommended Factor including a
summary of the outcome of each permit
application to which the state has
direct recommendations uh
recommendations on a methodology for
consideration of the mass measures set
forth in this section of section four of
this act and any other additional
consideration recommended measures to
provide greater or more redundant
protection of circles perennial water
body in a informing a site specific
setback that differs from what the
department would otherwise require under
its rules so that is basically
uh looking at uh the principles that are
used in other states now and seeing how
those principles could be can be applied
to improve our uh our rules in order to
make it more site specific so it's
really about determining the principles
rather than in doing an investigation on
representative Murray
thank you madam chair I was actually
curious that uh with regard to so this
does not get lost our desire to see
there being the house environment and
agriculture committee being given a copy
of said report would that be appropriate
for that to be here in uh
section on page four lines 15 through 18
or would that be appropriate to be
somewhere else
when we're talking about this the middle
of the final report well it says the
department shall make the report
available on its website so I mean we as
a committee can certainly
have that and review it
um
so I think we'll have it available to us
sure I guess I was just uh to may I yeah
I so I think we were at one point we had
discussed about the desire to have it
like just physically sent to the house
committee and I maybe I'm
represent Bixby yeah I I think that if
it is published on the department's
website uh and uh we received notice
that has been published there that's
sufficient we don't need to have a bunch
of papers sent over to us so uh or even
or even more specific electron sent to
us I think we can we can look at the
website and that that I I appreciate
that it's going to be on the website
because it means that the process is
really public
yeah may I follow up briefly
representative Murray so okay
look just
I
it just says that it shall be published
on the website
I think
they're good institutions I think that's
sufficient I don't think it needs to be
in the law representative germana
thank you madam chair on the issue of
reporting one of the questions that that
I've had is
so I think like a lot of people on the
committee I'm not happy with the
provision for a reversion to the old
rules but I also understand that if we
alter that substantially the likelihood
is is going to kill the bill
um Des is as assured us that they can
and will report within that 24 month
time period but then we have a provision
in the bill that tells us what happens
uh in in if they don't and where this
leads me is to to believe that
we need to stay on top of this process
even before we get to the end point
we're talking about now where they will
finally you know uh deliver a report I
realize we might not want to put into
statute that they would come back to us
at a regular basis or at a one year
Point say halfway through to report uh
but I'm just wondering what
uh
what
we can do as a committee to make sure
that we are getting some uh timely
reports you know for example I would
like to halfway through this process
have someone from Des come and talk to
us and and tell us where they're at uh
to give us a progress report to assure
us that they're on track that they can
deliver this within 24 months whether
that needs to be inserted I don't know I
just wanted to make it clear that I
think that that level of communication
when we're talking about the possibility
that we could revert to the old rules
after 24 months 24 months I think this
committee needs to have some reporting
maybe halfway through to let us know
that Des is in fact on track to deliver
that report within that time frame thank
you representative germano now
um in in this section here it says the
selected what page page four line 15 the
selected contractor shall complete the
assessment and submit a final report to
the department within 150 days after
contract approval
so they have a specific time limit to
get this report done and when the report
is done the department is going to make
it available on its website
um
I think it's you know a simple request
to have Des Supply us with the report I
don't think we have to codify it
and that being said
um
I would personally as chairman of this
committee
uh be kept you know I will keep on top
of this process and make sure that the
director comes to our committee to tell
us what the status is of this process
thank you very much Madam chair
representative Bixby yeah so I was
um
essentially following up on on what the
chairman said
um
or the um we have the capacity to not as
a not as not you know without laying it
out in a statute we have the capacity to
request uh any of the uh Department of
personnel who we work with as a
committee to come and give us uh reports
and uh you know providing them with
enough notice so they can organize their
thoughts but uh that that is within the
purview of the committee to request
updates from a department on ongoing
business so we don't need to put that
into statute another you know if we
wanted to uh set up a subcommittee that
would be you know
uh dealing with oversight that is
something we we have a we have the
capacity to do as a committee if so if
if say
um a half a dozen of us or or you know
plus or minus a bit wanted to be a
subcommittee to uh take into to
essentially continue to track this that
is something we can set up we have the
capacity to set up as a committee
without anybody's permission or without
writing any new laws
I would be amenable to that um I think
if we had a rule making
oversight committee a subcommittee that
might be a good answer to this and we
wouldn't have to put it in statute
yeah
so
um so I I'd like to say I think that Des
barring uh extraordinary circumstances
is entirely capable of doing this work
within two years uh what I'm concerned
about is extraordinary circumstances and
uh we had another department that I
worked with that we work with uh not too
long ago had one of their uh key staff
members leave on very short notice to
take care of her her ailing parents uh
that put things behind in the Department
of Agriculture for uh for several months
and so we know that things like this can
happen and we know that this is this is
the sort of thing that is out of the
Department's con Direct Control uh so I
would like to have I think that it would
make sense to have some sort of
um extension process available
for uh in case there are some more
extraordinary circumstances and uh it it
would it should be
um that it was Senator Waters suggested
that
um the appropriate person to uh provide
that extension would be the commissioner
of Des and that would be that the
commissioner could provide an extension
to uh the solid waste division uh if
there are if there are extraordinary
circumstances that are causing delays
and some of the things that I could see
as potentially causing a delay are the
loss of Key Personnel for health other
reasons uh failure to get a qualified
consultant on the first round of first
RFP round or disruption of customary
operation of the department or the
government from something like a
pandemic I think that there should be
something in place that would allow for
an extension and the length of that
extension is something that would be I
would need to discuss a little bit more
representative
um
Murray I'm sorry my my brain just went
blank I didn't know it was me no anyone
over there
um so in it so my question is uh I guess
to representative Bixby it's May I sure
um do you see this as a one-time
extension
is that what you're envisioning
um I could see the the commissioner
being able to provide you know one
extension or two extensions I I don't
think that the total length of extension
should be any more than a year uh and uh
I think the senator said he'd be
comfortable with two months I'm would
I'm not convinced that too much that I
think the two months might be a little
bit short I think we need to find out
from various stakeholders who might have
objections to this uh about you know
what range they would be willing to
accept
representative akantois thank you madam
chair what about if we put in like three
extensions of 120 days each
that way you have three extensions but
you're also pushing them under the gun
yeah um and yeah you're limiting the
length of each extension so that they
have to come back with a good reason for
that
representative Howard
uh one quick question uh thank you madam
chair so these these extensions would
push back the reversion time correct yes
yes
representative Morse
thank you madam chair I just wanted to
say that I think that this is a good
compromycin coming up with exactly how
many extensions and for what amount of
time I think
um you know three at 120 days is a good
idea but you know we can do a little
more research on that but I do think
that this is something that if we want
to see this bill pass we need to
compromise a little bit and it may not
be perfect but
I mean for me I
I don't think they'll ever need the
reversion clause
I mean they're gonna they want to get
the work done and and I think they will
get the work done in time
but um I also am sensitive and
appreciative of the points that
representative Bixby has brought up that
you know stuff happens and we do have
delays for unforeseen circumstances
we want to build in something here that
would prevent that reversion if those
delays occurred representative coulon
thank you madam chair I'm just curious
if there's a way we could put a
provision in to let DS use
um artificial intelligence so they won't
be interrupted by a pandemic or any
that's an interesting concept and I
think that
I don't know if they would they use chat
gbt
it's such a new technology I don't know
that they'd want to rely on that
but uh thank you
representative Murray um thank you madam
chair one of the things that I was
thinking of
um I personally
am of the mindset the department did say
that they felt like 24 months was
something that they could achieve I
agree given representative bixby's
exigent circumstances I would like to
see there being perhaps maybe something
three extensions possible around the
90-day term I mean I really don't when
we're pushing something out to 120 days
then we're getting into past a quarter
yeah
um so I would uh I guess caution going
that much further in each extension
yep
representative datsey
yeah I will
try to be
well I have to think about my wording
very carefully I will not be able to
support this bill
unless there is a foolproof amendment
that forces extensions if they are
necessary and takes it out of the hands
okay
so my question to you would be
representative datsey if the
commissioner didn't make that decision
who would
it would be automatic in other words if
they couldn't meet the 24-month deadline
that they would be forced then to have
whatever a 90-day extension 120 day
extension but that
extension would be mandatory so that the
reversion didn't take effect that's what
my concern is
would you require the commissioner to
give a reason why
they would need the extension
why the work wasn't done in time
no I mean I I think that probably would
be evident
um you know because of delays or
something so I don't think we have to be
that granular what my concern is this is
my third term I have definitely seen
changes or have perceived changes that
I'm uncomfortable with in the department
of environmental services so I think if
we don't want something to inadvertently
revert
back to a former permitting process that
we have to be very deliberate in making
sure that there's no wiggle room
and that the report isn't produced in 24
months and there's leeway in our wording
so that reversion can take place that's
what my concern is representative
germana uh thank you madam chair and
along the lines of of what
representative dutzy is has suggested I
could imagine a clause who would say
something to the effect of the in the
event that Des is unable to complete the
report within 24 months the director
shall request an extension up to let's
say 120 days and provide rationale for
that and so that directs the director to
apply for that so in that sense it's
automatic and with that extension there
is a rationale provided by the director
so to me that seems like it might be
able to accomplish a couple of purposes
okay so and I also want to be clear the
report is not the one that's done in 24
months the report is done in after 150
days and it's after the 150 days that
rules then can be
developed and go to gel car and
everybody else that needs to give its
blessing
um so and that's where we're going to
get into
where we might need an extension of time
because you know I don't know when
they're going to get this done
representative kantois thank you just
for clarification because I thought we
were talking about an extension for the
subcontractor if they didn't complete
their
report on time not the department I am
expecting that the department is going
to be working on rules and will have
their rules completed in two years I
mean
I don't know
they have two years to complete it
they're going to be waiting they're
going to start their rules now and then
they're going to take a look at what the
subconscious the contractor does and
then take that and integrate and see
where they compare where they're the
same where they're different and have
discussions about that but I thought the
extension was for the subcontractor and
well the the way this is written the
subcontract the the contractor or
subcontractor has to have their report
shall have their report done in 150 days
representative Bixby right so uh I I
expect that the subtract that the
subtract some car the contractor will be
held to that 150 day uh day limit that
is that that is in the bill and I and
Des will you know work with them to make
sure that happens I I am and I also am
you know I have
full confidence that Des can with all
things being equal
produce this produce the rules on the
time scale that is of two years uh but
if you know God forbid something happens
to the P to a person or persons who are
key to the process and Des and they need
to hire new people to take that on that
it will take time for that to you know
for that adjustment to be made and
that's the sort of thing where there
might need to be an extension yeah
exactly okay exactly thank you
thank you madam chair one of
one of We Were
all on the same playing field for is the
extension would also
include any advance is that correct
so
in a sense who's really going to be
police so let's say they hire the
contractor and it's not done in 150 days
there's not really anyone that's going
to be policing that
um so if it takes longer than 150 or if
there's if there's more money that they
need I assume that they're going to come
back and and and ask for that correct
I don't know I know but
I don't represent Bixby yeah so um so
the so
the money is one issue that um uh Des
feels that they can get someone for 150
000 and one of the uh you know if that
if it turns out that
um
on the first round of the RFP that 150
000 is not sufficient to uh uh to get a
qualified contractor then uh they would
be uh then Des would has it in their
capacity to go to the fiscal committee
and request enough money to uh get to to
get a qualified contractor so that is
something that we do not necessarily
need to write into statutes no I know I
know uh it is you know it is something
that we could put in uh if it would make
people more comfortable but it's not
something that that uh they need they
wouldn't need the authorization in the
representative Potenza okay so
um
first question kind of answered so yes
the 24 months
um and then having extensions I get it
so are you saying that we're gonna have
all of that have extensions in there and
still have the paragraph that states it
can revert back
is that what we're saying
representative Bixby yes so um so we
still have the the reversion paragraph
will still be in there and if there is
an extension then the reversion won't
happen until after any extensions have
been have expired and
I have been told by
um no Senators by
um by other folks who are aware of the
lay of the land that if we remove the
reversion Clause completely then we have
no bill and I am not willing to be in a
position of having no bill because
having a bill that we don't really
entirely like is a whole lot better than
having no bill
representative germano
thank you madam chair and I wanted to
say I appreciate your earlier
clarification
so we could know what we were all
talking about the difference between the
report which is 150 days as opposed to
the rules which is 24 months so I
appreciate your clarification I think
there were two
ways of thinking about the possibility
of an extension to the 24 month period
one
proposed by representative dutsy which
is not specific to say to a pandemic
it's an auto and it would be automatic
if Des is unable to complete their work
within 24 months whereas uh the
possibility that representative Bixby is
offered would be under extraordinary
circumstances uh I again I want to say I
come down in in that case with
representative representative dutse and
that if Des is unable to complete the
work within 24 months if we say the
director shall request
an extension up to let's say 90 days
right in that case it gives the director
discretion to determine it could be 30
days he could say look we're almost
there we just need a month or he could
say we need 60 days right so it's not
saying that it has to be 60 or 90 days
it would say for example up to 90 days
and provide a rationale and that I think
would
provide for the kinds of circumstances
that representative Bixby is referring
to right if there are those kinds of
extraordinary
extenuating circumstances but again that
would be in the rationale of the
director and again that request is
flexible because it would be up to and I
think that would also meet some of the
concerns of the stakeholders because if
the director were to come to the
committee and say we need another 45
days in order just to complete this
report report that provides the
assurance that certain stakeholders are
looking for that was the argument that
was made to us obviously businesses who
are looking to to get permits need to
have some certainty in in the market and
in in the process and so again if the
director were to come and say we need X
number of days in order to complete this
study I think that that makes sure that
we're not simply reverting to the to the
old rules and it provides the stability
and the assurance that stakeholders are
so there's two things
um that are that are in this and I don't
know if it really can be changed so
on page four under line 17 18. it says
the department shall make the report
available on its website and shall
review and consider the report's
recommendations when drafting rules as
we've already discussed rules are
already being worked on now so in all
actuality
this all this work
the department could actually not use
any of the information based upon this
line there is nowhere inside this entire
bill that says that they have to use the
information that is provided from from
this report
I understand what everybody's talking
about right you know we were told in a
committee about this paragraph
when you say in anything in any bill you
say okay you got to have it done by 24
months extensions whatever it doesn't
matter hey you have to have it done by
24 months unless you don't have it done
by 24 months it negates this entire bill
it can't be in there I'm sorry there
can't be a revert back at all because it
could
we always have to trust and verify and
so having it in there still has an out
meaning I don't care if there's three
extensions it still has an out and that
is a problem
representative Dusty
okay if if
I think we have a couple of goals here
you one of the goal
that we want to get rid of the 200 foot
setback and the other goal is we want to
make the process more scientific so what
if we said that
I mean basically uh there would be no
timeline on the extensions but that
there would be no reversion back until
the report was finished
okay or something to that effect so so
basically what you do is that we could
keep the wording in revert back
but if there was no but if if it
couldn't revert back
until the report was finished then no
matter what the time frame was there
would never be a reversion back so you
keep the wording
that
the other body
wants
but in reality it can't revert back
until the report is completed whatever
that time frame is representative
represents right exactly the rules not
the report thank you representative
Bixby
um I think that that would guarantee you
veto
and uh and my and I don't want to I
don't want a bill that's going to be
guaranteed to be vetoed because I think
that there is no chance of overriding
one
what a good time
um
so if if I was King for a Day I just cut
that whole reversion thing out
okay unfortunately I was on the colonel
and not a king
and I understand the environment where
uh you know we've been told that that uh
that that would
um
you know Force the Senate into into
disagreement with the bill got it so the
alternative then is say okay well we're
going to extend the thing out as long as
we can to keep the reversion away and
that's where the extensions come in
and
essentially that gives you
if you did if you did three for 120 days
for example that gives you another year
so that pushes the reversion out for
um and that I mean that
so that means you basically got three
years
and
but to me an automatic research
extension doesn't make any sense that
that just
you may as well just put 36 months and
call it a day
um if it's automatic you got to have
some way to hold the department to to
task to get the thing done in two months
in two years
um so I I I I I don't like this
um the way it's it's structured but I
like it better than getting the bill
vetoed and trying to overcome a veto so
that's sort of where I'm at and I I
would I would sign up to it in this
general form because of that over sorry
representative Howard
um I thank you madam chair I I want to
start by saying that I agree with
representative Creighton that uh and
Bixby that if we are um if we allow
extensions I think that we can probably
avoid reversion
um but the other ques that my question
is don't the old rules expire during
this process they expire next year
so they have to get new rules in place
anyway
if there wasn't a plan to invoke the
reversion
why are people fighting so hard to keep
it in the bill
representative Bixby
so
um
I don't know if everything was noticed
this but there's a profound lack of
trust in this region and uh so uh those
who uh the so there are some people who
the people who want the reversion in
there
are afraid that there will be an
intentional uh attempt to with
litigation to slow the process down
forever and uh and if the if there is no
reversion if it's completely open-ended
then the process then the new rules
could take forever and ever because
litigation was slowing them down
on the other hand uh those who
uh don't like the re the reversion
Clause think that uh the process could
be slowed down with litigation in order
to trigger the reversion clause
and
there is no good answer to that complete
lack of trust and we had to sort of
shoot somewhere in the middle and my
feeling is that the closest we can get
is a shot through the middle and still
get the bill passed is to have to put in
the extension and hope and I and I hope
that the Senate and the governor will be
willing to accept the bill with the
I'm sorry representative
just to follow up with what
representative Bixby was saying
um I wasn't able to be here last time
for this hearing so I went out and spoke
to the director
um specifically to ask him about the
rules in if it was reasonable that they
would be completed in two years and his
answer was yes and having worked with
the director for the last six years
um
I believe him to be a man of his word
and he's always been upfront and honest
when uh
dealing with this committee and So based
on what he told me
that is how I am looking at this bill
so
representative germana thank you madam
chair and I want to follow-up question I
think it was representative Howard I
think I but in any event the question
was about when the current rules expire
and the chair you answered that they
expire next year and I think that's a
further reason why it's important to get
something passed right is because uh the
the uh moratorium or the abeyance right
during the rules writing process I think
is critically important particularly
since the current rules are going to
expire and we want during that time to
have a an abeyance right so that
the department can continue to work on
on the uh on the rules so in any event I
just wanted to add that in as a reason
why I also agree that it is especially
important that we get something passed
this is this proverbial sausage making
process but particularly because the
rules expire next year I think we really
do have to
do something that has the best chance of
of getting through and providing that
abeyance
represent them now
thank you madam chair I was just going
to make a comment about representative
potenza's earlier two-part question
which is
um that this bill doesn't require the
report to be enacted I feel equally
concerned that the report that comes out
could say hey everything's great as it
is we're leaving in 200 footstep back so
I don't think there should be a
requirement that it's enacted because I
think there's a little concern about
what might come out of this report and
it might just leave things as they are
which is not I think what anyone on this
committee wants
oh thank you
representative Haskins
thank you madam chair so I have a couple
of concerns I think reversion is
untenable
um I appreciate the political
implications of how we get the most
protective bill because some of these
judgments are going to be value
judgments not scientific judgments alone
and because of that I want the maximum
amount of protection
protective language in the bill
however we decide that is
and I also think on principle it's not
pro forma that the legislation
legislative body writing the law gets
the report
I understand it's going to be on the
website I think it's a it's a statement
that says to the people writing it
this report is going to be received by
the people who wrote the Bill
okay
representative Bixby
I'd just like to follow up on
representative germanna's Point uh about
the uh the rules expiring uh on with
next summer and they will the rules will
have to be written uh but if they are
have to be written by next summer rather
than by the timeline in this bill uh
and without the input from that from the
consultant's study
I think we can be pretty sure that the
rules are not going to be as good as if
we pass this bill
and if we don't pass this bill then
we'll be you know we'll be stuck with
you know until the new rules are
published things can go forward under
the old rules and we will probably get
less good rules without this bill so uh
I I think that
um even though this bill is
I I there's the the phrase about the
perfect being the enemy of the good
which I think it might be overstating
the the the really good is uh we the the
almost acceptable is still uh we we
don't we I mean I don't think any of us
are going to like the bill that we pass
but I think that
we would even less like the bill that we
representative germana thank you very
much Madam chair and and to speak to uh
representative bixby's point which was
speaking to my point uh uh I would also
remind and also something that the chair
remind us of that with that 150-day uh
time period right for the report to come
back right so you're like in about five
months or so and then that report is
going to go on the website and and the
chair can ask the director to come talk
to us when that report has been
delivered and then we can ask questions
and and I think that speaks to
representative bixby's point about how
we can use this 24 month time period I'm
in the favor of automatic extensions if
needed but how we can best use the time
period because I'm also not happy with a
lot of aspects of this bill but I think
that we collectively can speak to some
of our concerns
through working with Des during this
process after the report comes back and
helped to shape the process in ways that
hopefully will make us all more
comfortable with the outcome thank you
okay
um so we are coming up to quarter to 12.
we could probably talk about this bill
all day long
but um we do have some time constraints
and I I just want to take the last few
minutes to kind of wrap things up um I
know
representative Bixby is working on an
amendment and I'm sure we'll take a lot
of the comments and thoughts
um and compile them as he's uh
writing writing up the amendment that he
will be sending to OLS
is that true well we
ascended and what I want
yes I would like to have both the chair
and the writing member's name on the on
the amendment whoever's name is first I
don't care but I want it to be you know
a non-partisan absolutely
thank you for that
so with that I'm going to wrap up our
work session for this morning
um and I would like to have a split out
into our caucuses so we could further
discuss the upcoming exec session this
afternoon
and we will be breaking for lunch um I
guess you could take now till one
Democrats
that's from the
environment Agriculture and this
afternoon we are going to exec a number
of bills so
um
and we have a substitute for
representative Brouillard a sentence
representative Karen Reed
um welcome
and
um representative Sophie Titus is absent
today otherwise we're all here I didn't
thank you you're welcome I think that's
what you were asking right Welcome to
our committee
um
so we will start with SB 162 and I am
looking for a motion
representative Dotsy thank you madam
chair uh I would like to make a motion
for OTP on SB 162 relative to exemptions
from rabies vaccinations for dogs cats
I hear a second my second
thank you representative Creighton
would you like to speak to your motion
uh thank you madam chair
um I think this is pretty
self-explanatory we've said before
um this is a um
uh basically making the law a lot easier
for owners whose animals have a severe
reaction to the rapes vaccination
seeing none I'd like the clerk to call
SB 162
OTP
representative Creighton aye represent
yes represent verville yes
representative Davis yes representative
Reed yes represent coulon okay
represent Kenny yes
representative Potenza yes
representative smart
no
representative Bixby yes
yes represents
uh representative dutzie yes represent
Murray
represent jamana yes representative
Haskins yes representative Howard yeah
yeah represent NAB yes represent Morse
18 to 1 motion passes and what I uh is
uh is it okay to put on consent oh sure
sorry
okay if we move on to uh Senate Bill 211
representative Creighton I move on to
pass please
do I hear a second
oh second
representative Morris seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
SB 211 relative background
investigations for solid wasting
Hazardous Waste Facility permit
applicants uh essentially what that does
is it streamlines
the process and uh
it makes it in compliance with Federal
representative Bixby yeah
uh one of the key things is that without
this uh the
um Des won't be able to do the
interstate background checks so they
need to be have the language aligned
with the federal law
thank you for that clarification
do I see any other discussion on this
bill
seeing none I call the clerk to call the
roll thank you madam chair it's SB 211
FN OTP representative Creighton yay
representative yes representative
verville yep representative Davis yes
represent Reed yes represent coulon
represent Kenny
represent Potenza yes representative
smart yes represent Bixby yes represent
dutse yes
represent Murray yes yes representative
Mana yes representative Haskins yes
representative Howard yes
representative NAB yes representative
Morse yes representative yes Madam chair
yes 19-0
to see that on consent
uh has a fiscal note oh it has a uh
okay
oh yeah yeah
ten thousand
okay
and I also I want to remind excuse me I
want to remind those who move the motion
that they are responsible for writing
the committee report and I'd like to get
those
I'd like to get those this afternoon
um or by this evening you can send it to
I'm moving on to SB 23 establishing a
study committee on meat processing do I
hear emotion representative yes I'd like
to move
OTP on SB 23. do I hear a second second
thank you would you like to speak to
your motion representative Compton thank
you madam chair uh right now we have uh
we have amenable and non amenable uh
species uh that are required to be uh
slaughtered at USD facilities
um the non-monal species are having a
difficult time and we really need to
look into alternatives for them and in
doing so that might help us uh
look at some other avenues also so I
think it's extremely important
for the uh people that farm non amenable
species to have this studied
thank you any discussion further on this
bill
see you none I request the clerk to call
the roll thank you madam chair uh SB 23
OTP representative Creighton yay
represent yes represent verville yay
representative Davis yes representative
Reed yes represent coulon
represent Kenny represent Potenza
yes represent smart yes representative
Bixby yes representative dutse yes
representative Murray yes representative
Mana yes representative Haskins yes
representative Howard
represent NAB yes represent Morse yes
representative yes Madam chair yes 19-0
and I request that to be on consent
but okay
all right
uh now we moved to SB 159 do I hear
emotion
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair I'd like to make a motion of OTP
for SB 159
establishing a committee to study
unlimited service area permits for
landfills and out-of-state waste coming
into New Hampshire enjoy here a second
I second representative Potenza thank
you
um representative Murray would you like
to speak to your motion please it was
Madam chair thank you good
um yes thank you so I think that the
committee believes that this is
something that should move forward given
the fact that um
folks in the solid waste working group
had indicated that it's an important
subject that needs to be looked into and
though they are not taking that up under
their purview it is something that we
definitely have the authority to do and
should
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the roll
thank you madam chair
OTP motion on SB 159--f-n
representative Creighton yay
representative yes represent verville
yes representative Davis yes
representative Reed yes represent coulon
okay represent Kenny
represent Potenza yes representative
smart yes representative Bixby yes
represent dutse yes represent Murray yes
representative jomana yes representative
Haskins yes represent Howard yes yes
representative NAB yes represent Morris
yes represent Voigt yes Madam chair yes
19-0
okay uh that could go on consent as well
with physical note on it uh let's see
okay moving along to SB 267 do I hear a
motion representative Bixby yes I'd like
[Music]
2023-1685h to SB 267 FN
and
do I hear a second on that
uh uh representative Bixby would you
like to speak to your motion yes so
um
SB 267 uh uh
has Des hire a person to look at the
issue of cumulative impacts uh of uh of
contaminants so the essentially the con
the impact of uh either multiple
contaminants from multiple uh uh
emitters in a particular area or uh
multiple different types of of uh uh
contaminants that might together cause a
greater degree of of health risk or
environmental risk uh so Des is going to
will this person in Des will look at
this and issue a report to uh the uh
legislature after uh on the the date
listed and the what the amendment does
is it changes the date uh of the
original date of November 1st 2025 to
September 1st 25 2025 and it makes sure
that uh the report goes to our committee
as well as Senate energy and natural
resources stne and resources Recreation
and development uh it also
um strengthens the uh the requirement on
the department so that um by by changing
the word if to the word what in line
five 5 and
on that uh
really indicates that the they need to
issue this provide this report to do
this report and provide it to our
committee and the other legislative
committees uh and I hope you'll all
thank you representative Bixby I
certainly will support this amendment I
think it really makes the bill a better
bill
are there any other questions or
okay
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the role on this amendment thank you
madam chair uh
SB 267 adopt Amendment
yes representative verville yay
represent Davis yes represent Reed yes
represent coulon represent Kenny
represent Potenza yes represent smart
nope represent Bixby yes representative
represent Murray yeah represent jamana
yes representative Haskins yes represent
Howard yes represent NAB yes represent
Morris president yes Madam chair yes
19-0 the amendment is adopted
okay wonderful then I need a motion I'd
like to move ought to pass with
Amendment uh one six eight five h on SB
267 FM
do I hear a second
representative Davis
seconds
uh would you like to speak to that
motion
um I uh I think that I've pretty much
covered it in the discussion of the
amendment so okay and and we also talked
about it this morning so if anyone has
questions I will answer them but
otherwise we can just move on okay I
then call uh ask the clerk to call the
roll on 267 as amended
thank you madam chair voting on SB
267-fn with Amendment 202316
85h representative Creighton yay
represent yes representative yay
represent Davis yes representative Reed
yes represent coulon represent Kenny
represent Potenza yes representative
smart yes representative Bixby yes
representative dutse yes representative
Murray yes represent jamana yes
representative Haskins yes represent
Howard yes represent NAB yes represent
Morse represent Voigt yes Madam chair
yes 19-0 we'll just go on consent I
okay we will uh then proceed to SB 62
I need your
yes a motion to OTP SB 62.
do I hear a second I second the motion
Madam chair thank you representative
Knapp
representative Kenny would you like to
speak to your motion on SB 62 yes on x s
b 62
um it basically changes the um ads
hazardous substances to the Hazardous
Waste um for cleanup
so it's just you know adding that those
words and it's also
adds owner rather than he or defendant
thank you any
questions or comments regarding
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and I think yeah uh to your point
I fully agree that
um it makes that change for the uh away
from hazardous substance to make it more
clear
any other questions or comments
okay
um I then asked the clerk to call a roll
on SB 62. thank you madam chair SB 62
with an OTP motion represent Creighton
yay representative yes representative
verville yes representative Davis yes
representative Reed yes represent coulon
represent Kenny yes represent Potenza
yes representative smart yes represent
Bixby yes represent dutse yes Murray
represent jamana yes represent Haskins
yes representative Howard yeah
representative NAB yes represent Morse
yes represent Voigt yes Madam chair yes
19-0 19-0 and I would like to see that
Beyond consent and he
questions about that
so um we have one bill left which is SB
61 which I had mentioned this morning
would not be exec this afternoon instead
we are going to schedule the exec
session for SB 61
um I don't know if I need to give a Time
certain but I would say 11 A.M that way
in the morning uh before that I'm I'm
planning on having a presentation
yeah okay
okay yeah so we would have a
presentation in the morning and then we
can exec that bill I know that you are a
representative Bixby will be developing
a um an amendment to SB 61. which
between now and the 23rd we will all be
so uh my plan is to work out the
amendment in the coming week and uh
touch base with
um whoever I need to in order to get
more feedback on on some of the details
and I I will share that with uh
representative
um Aaron and then representative Aaron
and I will be emailing it to our
respective caucuses so that we don't
have an issue with uh open meeting
issues an open meeting law and then give
feedback only to uh either me or
representative Aaron depending whoever
is your caucus leader uh so that we uh
so that we don't run into any open
meeting issues but we can still get
feedback and make sure that we are
addressing as many concerns as possible
okay
and I
would have the committee researcher when
you get your information put together
for the conflict of interest
issue that we discussed that you can
forward your report to me and I'll share
or send it to both of us and then we'll
disseminate it
so with that I guess we are done with
our work for today
unless
no if you have a blurb you got to get it
in oh that I said that I told that
everybody reinforcing okay get your
blurb into me
um so our work for this afternoon is
done and I wanna
I want to thank you all for
um a very wonderful and robust
discussion this morning of all of the
bills especially
the landfill bill I think
again this committee shines in working
together
And discussing the issues that are
before us and I truly truly appreciate
how well everybody works together and
it's a credit to every single one of you
here so thank you
and I just like to Second what Judy said
on that
yeah Madam chair do we have
um are those available electronically
the forms yeah I believe yes it is I I
had so so I can I had emailed them to I
had emailed them out to everybody
um but and I I can email it out to you
again if you would like I had sent out
uh an electronic version of it but if
you want to just write a a Word document
that has it formatted that way that
would be perfect okay yeah and get it
into you by five this afternoon
absolutely
okay
thank you very much everybody have a
great rest of the day and a great rest